[Musique]
à droite ou là là ou là là à gauche ouh
là là ou là là au centre ou là là ou là
là j'ai des soucis je lais un déc
MRG PTM ou PS pspr ou PC
rprcgt SOS mais dites-moi pour qui
voter le soir au fond des
voix du pauvre
lectorat mon l'angoisse mais à sa place
répond
[Musique]
l'OL
MRG PDM ou PS PSU ou PC rprc GT SOS mais
dites-moi pour qui votez je lis tous les
journaux j'écoute la
radio je me renseigne sur les problèmes
ça ne résout pas le MI
écologie écologie c'est
[Musique]
cornéli d'près le dernier son
d'ENT pour la gauche 49
tourons 49 tourons pour la droite les
indécid
décideront
feront la France ils feront les Feurs de
lois ils sont toutes notre espérance oui
mais lesc c'est
moiesmoi pourter ou ou ditesmo pour ou
ditesmoi pourot ou ou ditmoi pourot ou
ou ditesmo pourot ou ou ditesmoi pour
qui vot ou
dites-moi pour qui VE là ou là là DISM
pour qui v-tu ou là là ou là là dis pour
qui VTU ou là là ou là pour